[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon our speakers this
afternoon of course need no introduction
let me just say a few words anyway we we
live in a in a time of rising
expectations and we physicists I think I
know exception to what is going on in
the rest of the world our expectations
are rising also there's talk of a crisis
in elementary particle physics nothing
to do technological unemployment where
are we going to go all those questions
of course the crisis it's not really a
crisis is a reflection of the tremendous
success that that this field has had
over the last decades 46 years ago the
date we're celebrating they were
remembering 46 years ago it would have
been inconceivable it would have been
inconceivable to imagine that we would
have the understanding the knowledge and
the of the sub nuclear world that we now
have so it's hardly it's it's hardly a
crisis in that sense it's a wonderful
wonderful accomplishment it's been
reflected in a great deal in the talks
that we've heard today we have four
speakers all of whom played major major
parts in achieving this success in
learning the things that we learned over
the last 25 years it's an honor to have
them with us looking at the titles it
seems to me the first three speakers are
addressing the present the past in the
future and the last Steve is addressing
all of the above so we'll see the first
speaker is Professor Sam ting and his
title is muons electrons and gamma rays
Sam
it's 25 years ago
Ricky hired me at that time I had quite
a few offers MIT was the only offer
without Nu but nevertheless the I sensed
the great freedom and for research and
therefore I decided to come here unica's
I did not really understand for tenure
was in the case what I would like to do
today in order not to waste your time is
to describe a little bit there since
professor backer of Assam India and
others has been doing together with me
on physics of the electrons muons and
photons the first period covers from 65
to 72 in the deutsches electrons in
Cortona Hamburg my personal interest in
this field come from in 64 reading a
paper one was us-colombia by francis law
whom i did not know at that time and the
possibility of an excited electron go to
econ and that paper faceted me
frightening me a great deal as you all
know the physics of the electron
positron in fact Lewis once said this
morning already sent 14 849 and 50s
through the work of dodge and Kindle and
others who have the simplest electron
positron Collider and that is a positron
iam in 1964 there were experiment shows
the electrodynamics was violated
the experiment that was carried out was
supportive production of y
electron-positron pair in the fear of
Coulomb nucleus where you have a
momentum transfer so-called battle hydra
pair of momentum transfer a1 TV and
therefore your probe the electron passes
propagator to 10 to 2 minus 14
centimeter that experiment shows a
violation of the electrodynamics as a
function we plot eva g- environments
together with professor becker
we build a spectrometer which has magnet
and detectors the detectors defines the
aperture not the magnet and also two
sets of chunk of counters and separate
by magnets or the knocking electron from
the first one does not into the second
one and also the electron emerge or
twice wins with the shower and other
time would you like with the electron
beam with renkov counter this is the
picture of this first spectrometer we
may and this person is Stuart Smith
who's now the head of the physics
department at Princeton University the
measurement from us shows who had a
small disagreement with early
measurement and others in other words we
agree to with the prediction of the
electrodynamics and accepted the massive
role a master Phi and we see a deviation
this deviation come from the factor
photon a change itself to a row go back
row photon go to electron-positron pair
indeed at that time there were family of
three back some atoms have the same
quantum numbers of photon except it has
a mass not equal to zero which I will
call heavy photons
at that time most of the people would
discuss the vector Dominus model and
them see Bernie Margolies society they
did a lot of work on this and one can
then relate the current with the
quantities from contribution from Bravo
from Omega from fire in this spirit
photo production or vacuum item would be
diffractive in nature and this is the
article for that or data taken from
Scientific American shows photo
production or PI plus PI - mass as
function of angle the yield peaks at the
row and Peaks more forward or heavy
nuclei like the classical diffracting
scattering analysis of this can be
carried out in the following way you
have photon with the coupling constant
let's say gamma b square or 4 pi and go
into the nucleus and go back to pi pair
or k pairs and so this rate therefore
it's a quantity of the bank some major
nuclear cross section nuclear density
and the coupling if you take the ratio
the coupling disappear is a measurement
of radius and maximize our nuclear cross
x the first thing we measured was the
roots action potential and I see there's
accents here and this is a very accurate
measurement of the section would
potential across all the nuclei and the
accuracy at one point 1 2 plus minus
0.02 to a to the 1/3 once you have
measured that you can also look a
bactrim identical to a photon and the
indicator a + C - in which case you have
two coupling one photon Kodambakkam ada
with the mass of the photon and here
with the mass of the row and the
question therefore are they two coupling
constant the same
this is the measurement of a photon go
to new Plaza - photon go to row goes to
a photon go to the plaza - clearly
because the final states are the same to
have interference indeed you see the
interference interference it's a
measurement of this coupling constant
also the production phase the result of
this series of experiment shows the
coupling constant add math of the vector
major from Row 2 y plus Z minus is point
5 and from the fracture of scattering
where the photon mass is zero is also
point 5 and furthermore the row nuclear
and cross-sections like pie Neutron
cross-section at that time there was a
serious theory by dar and vice call
fight of Hope which you still remember
and shows they are the same and the more
important the coupling constant is
independent of the photon mass at that
time there was a a Patou and that is
they were experiment a CA and cornea to
look for a row to the electron Omega 2
electron a diffraction pattern and this
pattern was locked for long time must
never observe it is difficult because
the premium which was very small and
therefore you need a high rejection and
furthermore the weight of Omega is only
10 MeV therefore you need a very good
spectrometer and a new spectrometer was
pure and from this
one indeed observe a plus/minus mass
spectrum it's not only raw but a sharp
peak from Rho Omega interference you can
look to back to major photo analogy once
more I noticed a row goes to 2 pi Omega
go to 3 PI therefore they do not
interfere but Omega can go to a photon
photon going to go to a ro ro go to 2 pi
and therefore there must be I Omega go
to 2 pi and this indeed have us looked
and I think that time the most famous
upper limit was said by Jack Steinberger
and going to lootings and we have looked
indeed with a good spectrometer if we do
it very precisely you see on hydrogen
and carbon and let the red spectrum is
with RO along the point and the blue
lines are Rho Omega interference to 2 pi
a difficult measurement was carried out
on Phi 2 electron pair because the raid
was very low and when option 2 Phi
coupling constant and also fine nucleon
cross section agrees with the quark
model this series of experiment can be
summarized in the following way and so
at that time the so-called Weinberg for
some loop which is the partial weight of
Rho partial with of Omega partial with
of five mass of a triangular relation
and this is the Phi measurement Omega
measurement and the redline to row
measurement indeed the measurement
agrees with the bomber of son
so to summarize the early data works
just the decay back from maiden confirm
su3 theory the electron radius is less
than 10 to the minus 14 centimeter and
the question is are there any more back
some islands are high very high higher -
I should mention at that time there were
many young physicists working with us
Joseph Oskar who's now the associate
director of account for the main campus
a better with Busha professors mr.
Princeton and so forth and there's
others in ski Kerry Sanders and Solomon
also Robin Marshall who just received a
distinguished chair and Manchester it's
also interesting to report that the
early measurement eventually was
confirmed by E Plus D - Collider and for
reason I never understood the collider
resort was not better than the early
measurement by backers age but by
current sharing in the others now we
know photon and heavy photon are almost
the same and they do transform into each
other and we also learn how to use high
intensity flux of 10 to the 11th gamma
ray per second to obtain pipe a
rejecting larger than 10 to the 8th and
to have a mass resolution 5 5 MeV and
then the question is as I just said why
should be only 3 highway photon and all
has a mass 1 GeV and go to higher mass
and we went to Brookhaven so let me now
summarize the only two years I ever
worked in United States namely help
recover a Brookhaven life is somewhat
difficult because when a proton on a
beryllium you produce many many
particles the most difficult are the
electron pair because the radius one
part in 10 to the a that means to obtain
enough the electron pair you need 10 to
the 12 protons to have a pipe a
rejecting 1% you need a rejecting one
part in 10 to the 10
this is the design of this spectrometer
looks all the same but actually it's a
very difficult spectrometer this is
looking from the top you have three
magnet to chunk of counter measures the
electron and these are the detectives
majors the coordinate and measure shower
pending is in the horizontal in the
vertical plane the horizontal coordinate
modulator bending is the vertical plane
and therefore the bending made is an
SATA and Phi are decoupled from each
other so this is a the spectrometer
shows the magnet chunk of counters and
pulsating detectors the target was
arranged in a healing back and they are
separated by 1 by 7 point 5 centimeter
with 1.8 millimetre beryllium and it's
done in such a way so that the signal
can be traced from one point the
background from two different point can
be rejected the magnet was measured with
a three dimensional hall probe 100,000
points those days there were no computer
and they would mostly dumped by hand the
detector is smaller than a magnet
aperture therefore the detector to find
exceptions is something we learn from
Daisy and the magnet bends a charged
particle saw that and to an angle so
that the detector never exposed to the
target never interfere the neutron and
photons to have a rejection of ten one
part in 10 to the 10 indeed is quite
difficult when you have a chunk of
Conger of a harem go into a club counter
knocks the electron forward and
therefore a pion would disappear the
electron goes forward to reduce knocking
we use hydrogen gas at a smaller number
of electrons and we'll put two magnets
so that the low-energy electron does not
enter the second term--the of counter
and this a very nicely marenkov counter
with hydrogen the very thing on both
side and including a mirror which is
made at CERN workshop fully millimeter
thick and you can see one two or three
photoelectrons position sensitive
counter were made by auric Becker
there are hundreds out there are ten
thousand wires
none of them are broke the only
experiment resolutions one millimeter
the three wires a sixty degrees apart
and therefore the Sun is always a
constant
and the rate is 20 megahertz equivalent
to 10 to the 36 Roman acity and there
are designs that it operates always a
very low voltage because of high
radiation to have an electron you must
have a electron detector you must have a
calibration to calibrate is we generate
artificially from proton on the target
applied zero to the photon a plaza -
pens am a plus into a chunk of counter
lady - go into the main spectrometer a
coincidence enable you to calibrate your
detector on the electron artificial
electron beam
the cows you need to tend to the 12
protons so you have a 10% target and
therefore tend to refer particles are
produced to to stop photons electrons
and muons we use the five tons of
uranium hundred tons of lead and to stop
the pion care and so forth
we'll use ten thousand pound concrete so
generously lend to us by carl strong
from CEA and soft neutrons are still
left all over and we manage the
convinced Martine dodge was their
laboratory nuclear science director to
buy five tons of salt to stop soft
neutrons and this shows if you can see
it and this shows for the location of
the soul
in fact it's doing this experiment we
begin to know Martin George and he
really supported us and maybe you know
much effort to make this experiment
possible it takes whole wake to set up
the detector because all the children
cough counters must be mapped to make
sure the hundred percent efficient or
the chamber area a map to make sure the
hundred percent or counter efficiency
and timing a check and poor side and all
shower counters are calibrated l Act
would artificial electron beam or
voltage a check every 30 minutes or
magnets had reserved a reverse once a
day mainly because you want the
rejection a one part in 10 to the 10 a
mass resolution of imparting a thousand
it was also doing this time we begin to
know Herman Fishbach and since that was
the first experiment where inside us we
have been close interacting with a
laboratory nuclear science and
particularly dr. Fred IP and I have
benefited enormously from this three
gentlemen and so this is the result of
this experiment shows a proton a
brilliant function V Plus events in very
much indeed show a sharp peak which we
for the day particle the physicists in
this experiment there's a Packer burger
with Buju help to make sure the proposal
get approved the mentions are long ruin
encounter Colbert who is now a professor
in Marseilles water Toki the student of
Becker's now a professor Colorado and
there's a nice picture and so there's a
solenoid is my wife Susan and there's a
John Taco Bell and water Toki very young
at that time after that to look for
higher mass particle we did an
experiment at CERN is our and
essentially it was a proton proton
collision co2 photon goes to MU plus mu
minus you can look for new quark and you
look for to cube our distributions are
ASR is a new concept for 1/2 range of
protons and protons collide and
therefore the center mass we see Khoda
laboratory it's a new type of
accelerator made possible through the
personal strong support by victor
weisskopf when he was director general
now this is the is our experiment where
you have a proton proton collision these
are magnetized iron from the cannons
million cyclotron and these are very
large proportional chambers developed by
our attack and that's the first time we
enter into very large solid angle
devices i guess you couldn't see it but
we have to really take the accelerator
part in order to install this detector
and also during this time every since
that time we have had a very pleasant
collaboration with cars 12 and his group
and this installation of the experiment
and the salsa or ik Packer much younger
then and also this is the picture
professor min Qiang under the detector
and this is the large tube chamber
developed by oral packer and really made
to the subsequent experiment possible
the process and collisions and known as
the Trillium process so the first result
is to provide a very accurate check or
PP interaction in the time lag region
and this is a direct comparison of
scaling phenomena at the s equal to 62 s
equal to 44 and shows indeed the scaling
phenomena is correct also the second
thing is to see the effect of gluons the
first effect one can see is the
following
when you have a PP one goes to a photon
Cotonou plasma - the article Takalua as
a function for energy that if there are
so if there is a cooler on you making as
function for energy the transverse
momentum or PT will increase indeed this
is the PT measured from us and as a
measurement by Leatherman go by the
Fermi level and shows the fits to the
QCD prediction the second you see the
effect concerning also concerning
multiplicity if you look close on your
machine which is opposite to the MU
pairs a local transverse moment of MU
pairs and the in the opposite direction
for the glow of energy increases because
the balance of momentum and the
multiplicity increases
there were many young physicists working
at a large in Branson who's now a
professor University of California
transfer venucci in Paris five Sochi
Sugimoto in Kyoto
Roberto Patti stone in Perugia and
pierrots plenty knee now as a professor
in Florence after that we face the
question where shall we go for the next
experiment going to Petra or pet I want
to show this check which I received from
Viktor Baskov
one over alpha
the last bet as to who is first Petra or
Peck Vicki I still have this check no
now a path or you have a 24gb he +24 TVG
- Gustavo town and go to court and
electrons Petra is a accelerator which
has 4 into 4 places Castle Mark J Jade
and Pluto and and cello for detectors
the multi detector is a very simple
detector basically the calorimeter a 4
PI calorimeter major hydrants major
muons major electrons and photons this
is the market detector and shows the
large chambers made by Becker and
collaborators and this is the better
energy resolution it's about 25 percent
and covered observe covers about 95% of
the total energy the only mark yeah we
had the first group of Chinese who ever
sent to West and I went to see mr. Deng
Xiaoping he said how about training some
Chinese physical for us and I asked how
many he said how about a hundred and I
had to explain to him no fetuses are now
soldiers you have to select them and so
he selected ten and now new director of
Institute of high-energy physics and
also the one in charge of the picking
detector in fact Mossad Heinie's active
high-energy physicists come from this
team also in 1981 Spain decided to
rejoin high-energy physics group and
select Lee in a national way a group of
physicists to start working with us
Wang Antonio Ruby
and now it's in charge of the talcum
Factory Bernardo a device in professor
in San Diego Martinez is a professor in
Barcelona and most of them in Spain both
of them have returned to Spain to become
very very active there one of the things
we learn is measuring the plaza manage
to MooMoo and tau tau check of QED in
the time like reading in the space like
religion is a Plaza - goes to E + E -
and swung over s and therefore you take
out a propagator a 30-year eternity way
10 GB so the perfect agreement with QED
taking into account already the
corrections of course from this you see
the radius of the electron the muon tau
a less than 10 to the minus 14
centimeter and one of the important
thing was down by Gregor hurtin and
Harvey Neumann Harvey Neumann was
educated by Luo Osborn as you have heard
Gregor hurtin and the min can also work
on this and that was first reported by
Harvey Newman in the photon Yale in the
photon conference in Fermilab in Arcis
and the basic idea is very simple you
have a Plaza - go to antique or quark
and gluon day and eventually you see
three lobes of jets the three loop of
jet has no meaning as you you always we
see that the important things the rate
must agree with the QCD
in a shape must agree with - CT there
was a paper published abroad Roger
Rabbit in September 1979 and let me
define in the production plan since the
event has to be planar you have a cue
glue on cue bar and follow the
terminology of horror
Howard George I you project them
momentum in the in this axis which we
call major
along the thrust axis workhorse Russ in
the production plan this event must be
circular Alec or minor and therefore
major - minor is a flatness for 200
bladeless or blindness is essentially
the transwoman
transverse momentum of the glue
and therefore it must be essentially
zero of our 2d events because in which
case major you put a mine or the event
will be circular and based on 500 you
bend and you see the rate indeed agrees
with QCD and without QCD just a cork
model no matter what you change the
parameter you're not going to fit this
data and this is the in the production
plane perpendicular to the production
plan the shape also agrees with QCD the
shape agree with QCD it's very important
because there are many many models
essentially produce read yes and these
are the data in this the QCD this is the
phase space distributing and this is a
QQ bar distribution phase space of
course also produce three jet pattern
indeed with increasing or blindness or
the transverse momentum and gluon you
can see gradually with increasing you
begin to see the glow and yet when the
transverse momentum qur'an is very small
you have no fragmentation and the
criteria have a smart yet eventually you
have a 4:3 yet i mentioned this the
cause you will always see three jet
events and this is a 3d event and this
is a flat event a 12 TV and petition
event can be completely explained by a
cuckoo bar model without gluons
indeed before we publish or resort was
an earlier with orbit a so by porcelain
and which says they indeed have a fine 5
flat event for the QCD predict nine and
they said if the theory is correct we
must soon confirm this result with
higher statistics and with much more
improved
evidence and there's an article by
Gloria loop King I saw her I see here
her here and describing their the
support of QCD and gluons
this is a data from RJ and there he said
fairly clearly by the she with which
time people tend to forget who discover
what and fortunately at that time mister
sharper with the director general get
hold of everybody together and agree to
say that March sharper told us that
market group was the first to report
statistically significant evidence of
the three jet pattern predicted by QCD
sometime after sometimes people tend to
forget that but today of course since
I'm very different with higher energy
these are the data provides a backup it
reported this morning with high energy
that yet a much more collimated and you
can see the jet become much narrow a
good experiment and like a also very
difficult one was it you like to wake
effect from the existence of the zero
because of the accession of the zero the
forward backward asymmetry were it's a
function of GA this energy is about
minus ten percent if you define theta mu
minus which is back to you - if you want
to look for ten percent effect your
systematic error has to be better than
one percent because of that the market
detector actually can be rotated both
invite direction and also in theta
direction to cancel out a systemic
effect the experiment of E Plus D minus
2 mu plus mu minus was the CSIs of jumpy
areevo is here and also greater hurt
and this is the measurement of a plus C
minus 2 mu plus mu minus this is one
year before the discovery of Z and W
first you have to make sure your
detector has no asymmetry from cosmic
ray and also the low energy data must
only be explained by QED and then high
energy cannot be explained by QED and
agreed with the matter of glass Chuang
burg and so on and that also was
reported in physics today and shows the
curve which I just presented to you
indeed we were able to manage to measure
the asymmetry as functioning with energy
caused over very limited energy region
but nevertheless agrees with the
standard model and I think this was
originally the work I mean Ken and we
with this a very crude data we were able
to set a range of GV + GA together with
neutrino data we said that he arranged
for in this range today or Rebecca's
data shows now we're in this point much
work was carried out on the physics of
gluons one of them is a determinant of
the strong coupling constant strong
coupling constant essentially is the
rate of three tiered were stood yet
because in this case you just measure
this coupling the first order a strong
coupling constant is point two to
complete second order you have to take
into account not only the standard QED
graph but also the three grew one vertex
when you properly take into account or
the second order diagram your data
completely agrees with QCD prediction
the issue the work mostly done by Ming
Chen and Harvey Newman
and this is really a very difficult work
and let me just give you a feeling what
kind of systematic error that has
involved using different recommendation
model different detector parameter glue
and fragmentation function cutoff energy
transfers momentum in the fireman fear
model or in the spring model in the
changes in the point of one level and
this is the difference in the change of
the strong coupling constant was
functioning of the cutoff in the energy
in the pattern level and again with
difficult experiment just always
disagreement but it's plotting here this
curve come from Professor Ming Chen I
believe originally it's alpha s as
function years and this is the
measurement by Ming Chang and Newman and
they said the measurement by other
groups I knew at the beginning there
were factor two different unfortunate
after 86 now everybody agree with with
each other less it with him we also look
for new course and new folks can be
looked by the head so-called are are
sleepless he managed to her home versus
he plus e minus 2 mu and they
essentially measure pork charge with
different particles usage are peaks and
you see a shoulder those days we know
the first three quarks has a mass a 1 T
wave force quark has a mass 3 GE v quark
has amassed 90 V and there was a paper
by Kalasha at that time and says this
the sixth court mmm when you take into
account QC d must be a 38 TV is in the
Physical Review Letters and this is our
measurement of our and so as we have
managed to go to 46 TV and you really
see nothing at all when you take into
account
order data into account of the
electroweak effect and QED and QCD
Corrections and then you can set the
sides of the cork and the sides of the
cork would be less than 10 to the minus
16 centimeters we also look for many new
particles and now clear it was fun there
are many young physicists working with
us at that time our bridge boom HS Chen
mr. Chen who is now the new director in
Peking Peter Donkers a professor
University of Amsterdam heritance at MIT
jean-pierre Revo and vice Lord is also
assistant professor here this is a
picture of the very small Mark J group
and there's a Harvey Newman and let me
see there's a Jason mr. John who the new
director disappeared on Curtis the mean
Kent is my wife Susan just the ORAC
packer and jumpy river everybody was
younger than this morning or Rick Becker
making the effort at the lab at the 2627
TV Plaza - Collider and there we
mentioned we have our three experiment
in our three there are many many
physicists somewhat unfortunate so many
people not only from your nine states
from Bulgaria from China France Germany
Holland Hungary India Italy Korea Russia
Spain Switzerland and Taiwan they are
120 physicists from 16 us institutions
and this
it um the GU meeting during assembly of
the experiment and this is with one
third of the physicists and I should
mention during this during this time
Robert Byrd now who was the head of the
department and also at the beginning
Jerry Friedman who was the director of
Labrador no clear signs were most
supportive to get this experiment
underway these are really very difficult
scenes and particularly also Kerman who
really spend a large amount of effort to
support this experiment and this is a
picture of author Kerman with Tom Cabot
and doing among the visit two or three
experiment and two years ago I think the
MIT cooperation at the executive
committee of the MIT cooperation come to
visit our three and this is during one
of their receptions experiment now have
become rather large in somewhat
complicate for our three for example in
the last 18 months 60 papers are being
written being published by 150
physicists and it means it's really no
longer possible for a person to really
understand everything in detail
certainly not me
and Orick Becker mentioned some of the
major resort on number neutrino species
a radius of for lab hands and quarks and
massive Higgs and the parameter on
precision determinant heavy quarks
measurement called mixing imagine alpha
s and because this is a very precise
detector you can measure translation
matrix there are many different ways
major science where W or agree with each
other a model independently manager
number neutrinos in the universe lab
some flavor violation flavor independent
of alpha s e+ the - go to Z plus ETA
this has been a very difficult in the
house in the past
nobody state has agreed with them on the
color or which QCD and that's the first
time we managed to see it really it's an
experimental effect that previously we
talked to another group with QCD will
obtain the branching ratio and also
study the heart photon emission J
production and the mass of excited the
electron I was larger than 122 gb mr.
becker also making where some will go to
lab 200 while the first thing we can see
look for OB Higgs indeed we have a now a
very large effort to ask lab to go as
high energy yes one can if you go to 120
TV you can set a mass of Hick's already
to 120 GB you can set a mass of the
Higgs to 123 be the second thing it's a
very precise case of the electroweak
theory but comparing science where W
from 100 and lab 200 left 100 with a few
10 to the 6 or 10 to 7 events you can
measure the mass of the Z to 15 MeV
measure the parameters various
parameters enable you to determine sine
square W 2 plus minus 0.005 a lab 200
marital you plus the minus 2w pair but
measure the mass of a W to fifty MeV
since sine square W is 1 minus MW / MZ
you determine sine square W to 0.0003
this number must agree with this number
the third thing is gauge cancellation
which Ulrich backer also making and that
is the three diagrams must cancel each
other so the cross-section is constant
and that is more sensitively measured
the measure the forward backward
asymmetry and then particularly if
there's no triple-triple boat and
coupling the rate in the back row region
be vastly increased so since we come to
MIT first thing we have done is to
marriage a photon to the electron pair
has QED to the read define the radius 10
to the minus 14 merger Rho Omega Phi 2 D
plus D - check su 330 spectrometer has a
mass resolution 1% - rejecting one point
entered a luminosity is about 10 to 35
measurement was always done twice once
with momentum another time with shower a
broke Herrmann the detector has a matter
resolution one part in a thousand the
rejections one part in 10 to 10 the
luminosity is sent to the 36 again we
develop high rate chamber but duplicate
a measurement to obtain the higher high
rate is our is the first term we in turn
into 2 pi detector with a very good
rejection and developed a large area
chambers Apertura and that's the time we
develop a 4pi detector for discovery of
glue on and you plus the minus 2 mu plus
mu - we set the radius 10 to the minus
16 now we safely electroweak theory to
1% to the PB bar mixing said the mass of
Higgs where were four PI detector major
mu gamma 2 1 percent for the future as
the Gregor hurtin had making we will
stay here 94 95 a lap 102 few 10 to the
6 to 10 to the 7 was 3 to 4 years maybe
five to w pair at which time they are
basically part a few choices one choice
no error HC in which case the machine
will go 236 pounds and 36 punch
pause at W and Z and with a luminosity
larger than 236 another possibility
in fact indeed may may rightly - you for
new discovery coming era and to do EP
another is the phase 1 phase 2 of lab
which Gregor her dimension let me just
make a comment of ep
in this century since Rutherford and
Hofstadter and tinder Friedman Taylor
much work much discovery has been made
from me P add air HC with point oh six
jhalak TV electron with a TV proton with
the luminosity 10 to the third is 10 to
the 32 since the electron is stationary
and therefore the electron goes
everywhere and with low luminosity
basically you do not need to make many
mattr for any modification of our three
but with the adding of a forward
detector major protons compared to Hara
the center mass energy is factor 29 and
we have also looked into what did the
attacker will look like for EP order
essentially the pto Burrtec chamber has
an kilometer muon chamber can be kept
the same except in the forward part for
the proton we add a proton
colorimetry gregor mentioned if we go to
air HC there's a very simple design by
adding a 6 Tesla coil and put in
calorimeter and vertex chamber in this
way because you have a 6 Tesla coil what
you will happen is you will trap Odom
you low-energy particle and let them go
forward and backward only muons go out
into your detector another design is to
measure electrons and photons very
precisely by putting crystals very very
far away from the vertex the basic idea
is very simple addition of 3 meters a 25
G by PI 0 go to 2 gamma a 2 gamma will
be in two different crystals and
therefore you can reject the positive
I should mention since there are many
detectors now we will proceed for our
three detector upgrade at PPO EP only if
we have a unique design with unique
resolution unique design concept not to
the other general purpose detectors and
also a minimum cost if you cannot
achieve that we probably will not
proceed with this and we'll do something
else I must mention that much of the
result from our collaboration come from
the instrument rating development which
is something Vicky always think is very
very important I totally agree with him
and all by done by Eric Becker and
collaborators since 74 he developed the
highway chambers 76 largely of chamber
79 truth tubes noise known as draw tubes
or written only developed by him and 82
developed were three multi sample in
trip chambers and now it's continued or
hard he has a continual effort for R&D
now finally let me make a few small
comment from a personal experience when
I first come to MIT the group only four
people now the 600 in fact when I first
come to MIT
none of the researcher really were
funded by goe at all
and with the funding we were talking
about into the for now into the eighth
and the detectors come from -
coincidence - half a million channels
indeed if you look the number of
physicists collaborate with me and since
I come to MIT really unfortunately has
come up so you know most enormous
and not like population no clearly this
cannot have been possible without
without a strong support of the
Department of Energy para Walla Mayer
who is here Bernie he Dobrin perhaps
younger fallen pre-k and a no reader I
have a nice picture we wall admire pre-k
Williams had a conversation with my good
friend oh come in during a bomb of the
visit of our three but unfortunately
dela for us after this visit he decided
to take $1,000,000 out of our budget
it's probably because we served the
wrong coffee and I also want to take
this opportunity to thank the MIT
administration and also the ding of
Sciences and as well as the MIT physics
department Vicki
Herman Francis Jerry Friedman our burden
now are the Moniz and also from Peter
dmoz
to author Kerman also Fred airplane and
the staff of laboratory nuclear science
particularly most of the non-scientific
staff because for them it's not for us
for two sins for fun and her three have
become a very international vegetable
scene and this is the beta two or three
by the US Congress Committee on science
and technology to the foreign the
foreign international collaboration
subcommittee any way they can with their
own jet finally let me mention in 28
years and the most rewarding thing I had
was when $40
now first $10 was October sexy October
65 I bet it with the Leon Lederman
how long you take to complete the QED
experiment and second was August 74
paired with $10 with marish wort and J
particle and third was $20 from Ricky
thank you very much
[Applause]